when Bradley Arrowwood first came to
train my dog visit it sent me on a very
unexpected Journey when you killed your
victim you were how old 23. he was by
his own admission a hardcore Los Angeles
biker who killed a man he said had had
an affair with his wife you lured him to
a house you beat him you duct taped him
and he suffocated because of that that
in a broken nose yes and I was honest
with you and I said had I known the
facts before you came here I wouldn't
have had you here wouldn't have called
as you said before we go any further I
need to tell you and you told us the
whole story and I thought well here's my
opportunity to actually live the walk I
talked a second chance talk but can I
walk it there are so many people that
come back out or could come back out
that educate themselves and they don't
get the same breaks I got
the breaks that he got led to a
successful service dog training business
thanks to his own decision to change and
the change of heart of others including
Adam growwald I thought I have lots of
choices in terms of who I could ask to
help train my dog and I could go with
someone who doesn't have that particular
history the experience that I've had has
changed my experience of ex-cons in
general I Jerry Brown and someone else
changed too
Jerry Brown commuted arrowwood's life
sentence in 2017. his sentence was
commuted so basically you said Hey
listen I'm going to give him a second
chance but you still got to go before
the parole board and essentially they're
going to be a another small jury and
they'll decide whether you're let out
but he earned it
he's very impressive Jerry Brown now
retired and living on his Northern
California Ranch knows about Second
Chances let me just add up to you but
when he was elected as the nation's
youngest governor in 1974 he was very
tough on crime he passed the first
mandatory sentencing law in the in the
state that then led to a lot more of
those laws being passed president of the
alliance for safety and Justice Lenore
Anderson advocates for Criminal Justice
Reform many people are really not aware
of the history of the movement for
teflon crime it originated here in
California California was the state that
had some of the first laws enacted to
increase mandatory enhancements for all
kinds of different crimes then the
legislature got in the act and almost
every year they upped the sentences and
made them mourn more Draconian so the
result of that was from 12 prisons that
existed when Reagan was governor we went
after I left to 30 three prisons so we
went from about 25 000 people in prison
to 170 000. that Legacy Jerry Brown left
when he left office as governor in 1983
directly affected Bradley Arrowwood when
he was sentenced just 10 years later to
life in prison with no possibility of
parole and a death sentence basically
death by incarceration the crime was
almost 30 years ago and talking about it
like we are now makes you feel how
lost still lost why
I lived a lifestyle
feeding off fear
hatred and what has changed what really
hit home was
seven years into my sentence finding out
I had a daughter that was placed in the
foster care system she was told that I
don't love her don't want her and her
people for a living
she's seven I never even knew about her
and that night I just kind of everything
hit me that one no child should be told
that that means she's a victim of what
I've done
he found opportunities inside prison and
seven years later I had to AAA degrees
two Associates degrees how did you find
your purpose in prison trying to do
better for my daughter
I wanted her to not
be ashamed
at who I was I had to be an example even
though there was no chance of me getting
out I wasn't able to tell her that I
wasn't getting out ever because I didn't
want to destroy any hope that she had
but why you were never going to get out
because I didn't want her
to be able to say that her dad was a
failure
then in 2010 Jerry Brown was elected
governor again but by then he wanted to
undo the heavy sentencing laws he had
championed as a young Governor now I was
a politician uh certainly I I moved for
that mood I do think all the time that I
was always looking for ways to temper
that very aggressive approach but if you
ask me what I preferred to do
differently yes I would acknowledge that
a fast forward a few decades after all
of that tough Justice gets put into law
and what the state has is a prison crowd
in crisis the one-size-fits-all prison
first approach that California
championed for 20 or 30 years
bankrupted the state when you were
Governor the second time it wasn't just
sort of your morality and your
conscience that led you to think we need
to give people a second chance you also
the federal Court's telling you your
prisons are overpopulated and you've got
to reduce that yes that was a big nudge
without the without the federal court it
would very hard to do as much as we did
by then California's bulging prisons
included 4 000 inmates who had no
possibility of parole including Bradley
Arrowwood he was at California State
Prison Lancaster where he had become a
model prisoner of the senior maintenance
mechanic in there okay so they come to
you and they say hey want to learn to
train dogs it's something positive and
the program specifically the program was
to train dogs to be service dogs no not
originally it was just to give dogs a
second chance
dogs that were in high kill shelters
like we were in prison to give them a
second chance at being adoptable the
prisons program was fittingly called
pause for Life those dogs gave us back
our Humanity it brought emotion back
into prison but
to come back out here
if it hadn't been for the the dogs
I wouldn't have been able to function
dog training was also a prize program of
the warden who recommended that
arrowwood's sentence be reviewed by the
governor the only man who had the power
and now the conviction to commute an
inmate sentence in commuting your
sentence Brown didn't free you brown
just said I will give you the
opportunity to prove yourself to my
board when he faced the parole board in
2018 the Los Angeles County district
attorney objected to his release saying
his offense was especially heinous and
his history of abuse of drugs makes him
an unreasonable risk
still though members of the parole board
unanimously agreed to release him saying
he had a good background to succeed on
the outside by then he had served 25
years in prison when I say the name
Jerry Brown
it's a miracle
ever met him no I haven't
want to I would love to
so we invited him to travel with us come
on by to meet the man who had the
biggest impact on giving him a second
chance so Woody how are you feeling
kind of amazed I had a million things
written down in my mind but I don't even
know how to say how much
thanks and gratefulness for you taking a
chance
had you applied before no so you just
there was never any hope tell the
governor what you've done with your life
since you got out when I first got out I
went to a transition home
to adjust after 25 years from there I
attended Cal State LA as a full-time
student and graduated with a bachelor's
degree in organizational and applied
Communications I got married to a girl
I've known since eight years old started
my dog training business you got any
ideas on what we ought to be doing with
our prisons
well I think we need to kind of go back
a step to where it used to be that
people get a chance to earn their way
out not necessarily just get let out
without any skills or being able to move
on and go right back to what they knew
before was granting commutations in some
way cathartic for you you know in fact I
was in the Seminary for four years I I'm
very sympathetic to Redemption I don't
think
yeah this idea the lock open through the
key away I never I never had that idea I
wouldn't say it was a cathartic process
it was a it was a very intensive process
yes before we left there was another
opportunity for some Behavior
Corrections what
what yes
come for the Governor's own dog yes we
could train this dog in no time yes I
can do wonders in a couple of weeks
the dog also is therapeutic in the
senses when they're focusing and caring
for something just like us prisoners it
gave us time not to think about
ourselves
you know the dogs really saved us in
there
while arrowwood's dog training business
continues to thrive thanks to dog owners
willing to take risks on him he's so
happy to see you the risks that he has
taken has led him to be the father he
never was to the daughter he hardly knew
she is now 29 years old with a son they
are a whole family living a second
chance everybody wants hopes somewhere
in the back of their mind that they can
be good that we're not all bad that
little bit of investment in somebody
gives a person a lot of incentive to go
a long way